I'd like to share with you some really
unusual symptoms that are associated
with a vitamin C deficiency things that
you probably have never heard before you
may know if you're deficient in vitamin
C you're going to get bleeding gums or
you might get tired or you might have a
loss of collagen that can show up in a
lot of different ways with your skin
joints tendons ligaments things like
that you also probably know that people
take Vitamin C when they get sick
because a deficiency can create a
lowered immune system I recently did a
video talking about vitamin C
deficiencies in increasing your risk to
getting biofilms which can actually be
the plaquing or tartar in your teeth but
I think what's even more important is to
understand what vitamins really are what
actually does a vitamin do
many people don't really know they know
it's associated with their health but
what is that vitamin doing in your body
vitamins are cofactors now what is a
cofactor it's something that works with
15 different enzymes without vitamins
and certain minerals these enzymes can't
work now what happens when you're
deficient in vitamin C is your body is
going to start allocating the vitamin C
that you have to just the essential
enzymes to keep you alive okay not all
of them so this is the reason why some
people have certain symptoms of a
vitamin deficiency but not others they
may have a subclinical deficiency but
they don't have a major deficiency but
you do have to realize that if you
completely run out of vitamin C you will
die it's very fatal you know scurvy
which is a severe vitamin C deficiency
became a really big problem when they
started to use pasteurization like for
milk and giving it to babies babies
would end up with scurvy so heat does
degrade vitamin C now that you have that
information let's go through some
symptoms that you probably never
connected with a vitamin C deficiency
number one hypochondria that's right
hypochondra is a symptom of a vitamin C
deficiency which is pretty wild and I'm
going to put the references down below
so if someone's a deficient about
vitamin C they can literally be kind of
paranoid thinking that they have every
single disease around when they really
don't that's interesting depression is
another symptom of a vitamin C
deficiency
this next one is called periphollicular
hyperkeratosis now what is that
Perry means around the follicle like the
hair follicle and hyperkeratosis is kind
of like a roughened red little scaly um
skin lesion that is around the hair
follicles and sometimes the hair
follicle coils okay that is a vitamin C
deficiency so if you have it you should
start taking vitamin C
number four anemia
we think iron B12 but we don't really
think vitamin C a vitamin C deficiency
can cause anemia dry hair
inflamed veins as in spider veins
shortness of breath
also vitamin C is needed for the
adrenals so you can have a problem with
your adrenaline if you don't have enough
vitamin C now where do we get vitamin C
it's in fruits and vegetables right now
there is some vitamin C in beef liver
but it's only like 27 milligrams per 100
grams of liver okay that's not too much
the rdas are the requirements that our
body needs is roughly about 70
milligrams and this is 27. steak has
some vitamin C but it's 25 micrograms
right not milligrams just a tiny bit
but mainly if he berries Peppers
sauerkraut has the most is like 10 times
more than anything else or leafy greens
you're gonna get your vitamin C however
if you get a hundred percent apple juice
right it says right here it's high in
vitamin C it says in the back of a label
if you drink one cup you'll get a
hundred percent of the rdas for vitamin
C well could this be true well let's
take a look
all right so we have a large apple and
one cup of apple juice which comes out
to 237 milliliters okay if we take a
look at the sugar and we compare it we
have one two three four five six
teaspoons of sugar and one apple and we
have one two three four five six seven
teaspoons of sugar in one cup of apple
juice the thing to know about is this
thing right here this is one teaspoon of
sugar this is how much sugar that we're
supposed to have in all of our blood at
any given time one teaspoon of sugar
that's in our entire system all of our
blood right the amount of sugar that an
average person consumes well I'm not
gonna even get into it because it's just
way way too much so if we were to chop
this apple up you know it'd be roughly
like one cup and so what I want to show
you is the amount of sugar in one apple
is almost the same amount of sugar in
one cup of apple juice however the
effect on your hormones from eating an
apple versus juice is drastically
different when you're consuming juice
without the fiber you're going to get a
big spike in blood sugars and you're
going to get a rebound effect of insulin
coming in to push that blood sugar down
which is going to make you hungry and a
little tired about 30 minutes after
drinking this juice versus an apple
which has a good amount of sugar but it
also has the fiber which buffers this
blood sugar response so fiber kind of
dampens out the spike in blood sugars
there's actually two things that will
lower this blood sugar insulin response
one is fiber and the other is fat so if
you were going to have the choice of
consuming these two of course this would
be better and if you added fat with this
as in maybe some nut butter on your
Apple you would buffer the insulin
response even more and of course I'm not
recommending this because there's still
a lot of sugar in here but if you were
to have the choice this would be a much
better choice and of course adding The
Nut Butter would even be a better choice
now what's interesting about this apple
juice
it says 100 apple juice not from
concentrated okay but if you look really
close right here it's hard to make this
out what this says it says with added
ingredients what are the other
ingredients
well it says apple juice and ascorbic
acid ascorbic acid why are they putting
ascorbic acid in there well the answer
lies in the expiration date it says
September 23
2024 it's 2022 right now it's November
2024. so this is going to expire in like
two years how can this sit on the Shelf
without being refrigerated for another
two years well because it's pasteurized
okay that's heated one thing that is
interesting to know about vitamin C it
is very sensitive to light and heat okay
as in pasteurization even at
temperatures at 86 degrees Fahrenheit
you start to break down vitamin C the
temperatures they use to pasteurize this
juice is like 185 degrees Fahrenheit so
as you can see they destroy the vitamin
C in apple juice and they have to add it
back in there so so that way unlabel
they can say it's high in vitamin C the
only problem is the source of vitamin C
they're using doesn't come from natural
apples it comes from cornstarch and
sulfuric acid it's made synthetically
it's out of the normal vitamin C complex
it's basically a synthesized version at
a part of vitamin C called ascorbic acid
I have a very interesting video on the
real vitamin C check it out I put it up
right here